- The Trump administration
is considering stimulus aid
for oil and gas producers
as oil prices plummet.
Wisconsin's Republican leaders
are suing over the Democratic
governor's lockdown order.
People stuck at home worldwide
have been a boon for Netflix,
adding nearly 16 million new subscribers.
Hi, I'm Jason Bellini
with the latest reporting
on the coronavirus crisis
from The Wall Street Journal.
- The energy business
is very important to us.
- [Jason] As oil prices have collapsed,
the Trump administration
is weighing stimulus aid
for oil and gas companies.
People familiar with the
matter tell The Journal the aid
would come in exchange for
government ownership stakes
in companies or their crude reserves.
This plan is one of several
options on the table
and faces long odds given Democrats
will likely oppose using stimulus funds
to help the oil industry.
Separately, the president
also said he would support
a $484 billion aid package
for small businesses and hospitals.
It's moving to the House
after the Senate passed it Tuesday night.
Republican law makers in
Wisconsin filed an injunction
targeting Governor Tony Evers' order
for businesses to close
and Wisconsinites to
stay home through May 26.
It's the latest in a growing debate
around efforts to slow
the spread of the virus
while not constricting the economy.
Republican leaders argue
they weren't consulted
about the decision and that
restrictions should be eased
in rural counties where
there are few cases.
The governor's
administration says the order
has slowed the spread of the infection
and prevented deaths.
Meanwhile, Attorney General William Barr
said the Department of Justice
would consider supporting
those who alleged their rights
had been violated by the
strict lockdown measures.
Netflix scored 16 million new subscribers
in the first quarter of 2020.
That's more than double
what the company had forecast
but the streaming giant
said the breakneck pace
of growth was unlikely to continue.
Its stock is up 34% year to date,
making the company one of the few
to see shares appreciate
during the coronavirus crisis
as people stuck at home around the globe
are turning to streaming
services for entertainment.
Most of the growth is from
outside of North America.
Netflix has a challenge ahead of it.
Practically all of its content production
has ground to a halt due to the pandemic.